une histoire qui remonte à l'acte 8d
gilet jaune le 5 janvier 2019 ce jour là
christophe dettinger ancien boxeur
professionnel l'affront plusieurs
gendarmes à main nue sur une passerelle
parisienne le lendemain une cagnotte
litchi est ouverte pour le soutenir
le nombre de donateurs explose en deux
jours le montant atteint 145 1000 euros
face à cette somme importante les
critiques de syndicats de policiers les
pressions politiques se succèdent le 8
janvier
leetchi décide de fermer la cagnotte au
grand désarroi de christophe dettinger
dans la foulée l'ancien champion de
france de boxe attaque la décision de la
plateforme
il réclame 3 millions d'euros de
dommages et intérêts pour combler la
suspension de sa cagnotte de son côté
litchi affirme que l'initiateur s'était
engagé à ce que l'argent récolté soit
destiné exclusivement à couvrir les
frais de justice du principal concerné l
litchi s'engage à ce que les fonds
collectés sur la cagnotte de soutien à
christophe dettinger servent uniquement
à financer les frais de justice
conformément à nos cgu et à la
législation en vigueur
en effet nos cgu proscrivent toute
incitation à la haine ou à la violence
compte tenu des acteurs reproché à
christophe dettinger aucune autre
utilisation de la cagnotte ne saurait
être accepté en février 2019
celui que l'on surnomme le gitan de
massy et condamné à 30 mois de prison
dont 18 avec sursis pour violences
volontaires sur deux gendarmes
en janvier dernier la sphère du
versement de sa cagnotte avait été
renvoyée au 19 mai une décision pourrait
donc être rendu dès aujourd'hui